Here's a question for aspiring
screenwriters.
Is it possible to make the movie
passengers better with some relatively
minor changes?
You know,
I don't think this is a really bad film.
After hearing reviews from friends and
online,
I sort of expected it to be,
but I think that feeling was mostly
disappointed.
Expectation passengers is by no means a
train wreck.
It's just really,
really predictable to the plot goes like
this.
After the interstellar spaceship,
avalon malfunctions,
Chris Pratt wakes up from hyper sleep 90
years before he supposed to 90 years
before anyone else on the ship.
You can't go back to sleep.
You can't contact her if you can't get
to the ship's controls.
He tries to do all of these things and
fails.
As a year passes.
He grows increasingly sad and hopeless,
so eventually he decides to wake up
another passenger,
Jennifer Lawrence condemning her to the
same fate,
essentially death in order to give
himself some more company.
He acts like gets another malfunction.
He doesn't tell her after a while,
they fall in love.
She finds out the truth gets really mad,
and then the ship begins to really
malfunctioned.
So Pratt sacrifices himself to save it,
but in the end she saves him a fall in
love again and spend the rest of their
lives alone on the ship happily ever
after.
Oh,
and Laurence Fishburne send it to about
12 or 13 minutes and act three,
but you know,
count your blessings.
It's way better than what Oscar
nominated actor Andy Garcia got.
So you can break this blood up into five
basic turning points.
One,
Chris Wakes up to Chris Wakes Jennifer
up.
Three,
she finds out for Chris Sacrifices
himself and five,
she forgives him.
The most acute tension in the film
happens between parts two and three.
When Jennifer starts to fall in love
with Chris,
but doesn't yet know the truth.
We know the truth is coming.
There's a little dramatic irony there.
And so we wait with increasing anxiety
until it does and when it does,
predictably,
Jennifer freaks out predictably and we
feel a little sadness predictably at
this point,
exactly an hour into the movie.
The script has sort of written itself
into a corner because Pratt is the real
main character because we spend 30
minutes alone with him at the start of
the film and see everything through his
eyes.
There's really only two paths to take
regarding the central relationship.
Either he dies or she forgives him in
both ways.
He finds APP solution for the sin he
committed because you're not going to be
able to turn him bad.
Not a character like this,
not unless you have five seasons to do
it,
and yes,
I know there are some illusions to the
shining here,
put the shining,
spent pretty much no time at all and
deering us to the character of Jack
Torrance.
Passenger spends the whole first act and
during us to the lovable,
scrappy,
Chris Pratt.
It's clear the creators or the studio
were intent on this being a love story,
so they chose to go with the schmaltzy
ending,
but they could have chosen either the
last 45 minutes would have been the same
movie,
pretty much devoid of real tension or
suspense,
which requires a completely new plot
device.
In the third act.
The total malfunction of the ship to
juice,
the ending with some adrenaline.
You know,
a couple of weeks ago I was watching
Chris Sztokman and Doug Walkers,
joint review of passengers and Walker
said something interesting if they told
this in a different order.
Yeah.
When have been 10 times more
interesting.
The thing I began to wonder is what if
you rearrange the movie so that Jennifer
Lawrence was the point of view
character,
not Chris Pratt.
What if the film began with her
experience?
Well,
I couldn't stop thinking about it,
so I re edited the existing footage.
See what would happen to the story.
Good morning,
Aurora.
How are you feeling?
You just spent 120 years of suspended
animation.
Grand Concourse.
Anybody?
Hello?
Hi,
he passenger or crew passenger?
Jim Preston.
Do you know what's going on?
Nobody else from my Robo Cup.
Same for me when I made this change and
just watched from there some interesting
things started to happen.
First of all,
the first act changes its tone entirely
with the original first act.
You're wandering around the ship with
Chris Pratt.
You learn cool things.
You see him come to terms with the
situation,
have fun,
get depressed,
and finally reached the ethical dilemma
that's meant to animate the movie.
What you see is what you get here,
which makes for a somewhat passive
viewing experience.
It's an amazing sequence,
but that's mostly down to cool
production design and pratts always
charming performance.
I guess I am going to die of old age on
this ship,
but in the new first act,
the story is infused from the start with
mystery.
When I made the editing changes,
I was genuinely surprised by just how
creepy pratts character is.
When you take away his point of view,
we don't know whether to trust him or
not,
believe him or not,
and that makes the audience's experience
an active one in every moment to you
know what's going on.
Nobody else from my robot
cut.
Same for me as he leads Jennifer around
the ship locations become crime scenes
where the viewer tries to figure out
what's happening.
This of course,
by the way,
is what makes Andrei Tarkovsky Solara so
great.
So much has happened on Solaris by the
time the lead character arrives that he
and the audience have to piece the
fragments together themselves.
I mean,
just look at how creepy he is.
I actually think that pratts performance
takes on more dimensions from this
angle.
You're not always forced to see him as
sympathetic,
so his darker side comes out in greater
relief.
More important than that.
That dark choice that sits at the heart
of this film hits with greater impact
when seen from the first time from
Lawrence's perspective,
because we feel the cruelty as she feels
it too to your wake me up.
I try not to,
so now we're at the point where the
original story hits that dead end,
but with this new edit,
you have some more options to play with.
Namely with this configuration,
you could actually turn Pratt into the
villain.
The original film suggests that can't
follow through on and make passengers
into the thriller horror film that so
many critics wanted to see.
You could even cut back in that whole
first section of Chris's time alone on
the ship,
but put it after the revelation without
the need to justify his good guidance.
You could show a deeper,
more desperate side to his loneliness.
Something that I think actually would
make him more sympathetic in the end and
the choice he makes more agonizing.
Of course,
the simple cut and paste doesn't solve
every problem in the script.
The ending,
for example,
there's still an issue.
I think you'd want to remove the
malfunction macguffin,
but it might be just as trite to close
the story and true horror fashion.
It could be cool to give it a twilight
zone ending as Peter Spread at slashfilm
suggested and have di and Lawrence get
so lonely that she begins to contemplate
the same horrible choice.
Brainstorming like this is obviously
really fun and much easier than actually
writing a movie and making one for all
its faults.
Passengers is a big budget movie with a
completely original script and that
should be celebrated because it's a
dying breed,
but if I'm like,
this is a good opportunity for would be
screenwriters to think about story
because you can learn just as much from
films that don't work as you can from
those that do.
Everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
dollar shave club.
Might have noticed that I have a beard.
Everybody with the beard will tell you
that if you don't keep things clean,
it can get really scruffy really
quickly,
so I use dollar shave club razors to
make sure all the lines on my neck and
cheeks are smooth and even and it's the
smarter choice because they send
everything you need right to your door
at an affordable price.
You have to go to the store.
You don't have to spend money on
unnecessary technology and for a limited
time you can get the executive razor
with a tube of Dr.
carver's shave butter for just $5,
no shipping fee and razors are only a
few bucks a month after that.
Here's what you get in the box,
get a nice sturdy handle and get your
four razors and of course Dr Carver's
shave butter.
Don't leave home without it.
Makes shading really easy,
no commitments,
no hassles,
and if you go to dollar shave
club.com/nerd
writer,
you can get that first month for $5.
The links at the top of the description,
that's dollar shave club.com/nerd
writer.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next week.